ensuring the economy recovers quickly
after the kovat 19 crisis must be a
priority of the next EU long-term budget
MEP s will debate future EU financing
and call for the recovery package to be
directed where it will have the biggest
impact on people digital technology
climate change migration the world is
changing fast
MEP say the coronavirus crisis
highlights the need for European reform
they want the future of Europe
conference to be organized by this
autumn and involved citizens academics
and institutions to shape how the EU
will meet the challenges of the future
Parliament will set out its position for
a new EU partnership with the UK MEP s
will insist on the need to abide by the
agreements already signed between the EU
and the UK they'll also continue to
support the principle of a level playing
field as the basis of any future trade
agreement reopening Schengen area
borders closed due to the pandemic
should be a top priority according to
parliament civil liberties committee
members will vote on a resolution
calling for a swift return to freedom of
movement to ensure temporary border
controls
don't become semi-permanent
demonstrations have been held across
Europe and Beyond in support of the
growing anti racism movement sparked by
the death of George Floyd at the hands
of Minneapolis police MEP s will debate
the situation
you